well guys it finally happened it's true
I finally have the Hogwarts I can see
platinum trophy as the collector's
edition trophy bug that has plagued the
game since launch has finally been fixed
but that's not all we've got new
Hogwarts Legacy merch new secrets and
Easter eggs to discover a free way to
try the game if you haven't played it
yet and we'll also talk about when we
might hear more about the future of
Hogwarts Legacy including a possible DLC
and or sequel so to start back on June
2nd Hogwarts Legacy put out a tweet
saying your trophies may not need
polishing due to slug slime but they did
need a little bit of upkeep and we've
done that for you the latest patch for
Hogwarts Legacy is live now there were a
number of additional bug fixes as well
as several performance improvements
across all platforms for the game so if
it's been a while since you checked into
the game now may be a good time to pop
back in especially if you were having
trouble with the trophies or
achievements like I was for our next
update we also have new official
Hogwarts Legacy merch that you can buy
right now and this is particularly
noteworthy for all our slytherins out
there because not only do they have
multiple designs featuring Slytherin bad
boy Sebastian sallow they also have a
new design featuring the heir of
Slytherin himself ominous gone and it's
not just one
that's right another ominous gaunt shirt
and we're not stopping there we've got
more designs coming for the characters
beasts and things you love from Hogwarts
Legacy these are all in addition to the
standard Hogwarts Legacy merch that has
been available since launch if you're
interested check out the affiliate links
in the description below as it's a great
way to support the channel here at no
extra cost to you that is if you're
interested in some pretty cool Hogwarts
like sea merch now speaking of how
Slytherin our community manager Chandler
wood was featured in a brand new video
on the official Hogwarts sexy Channel
revealing 74 Easter eggs and details you
missed in Hogwarts Legacy well some of
you missed many of these we had found
and discussed on the channel before in
some of our own Secrets videos but it
was great to get confirmation that we
were right on a lot of these that being
said there were a few that I hadn't
noticed or seen anywhere before this
video like the fact that Headmaster
black has a mirror designed to look like
a chocolate frog card they actually put
an area in the game designed to look
like newt's Commander's Nook from
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
and there's even a special detail in
feldcraft that only appears after you
finish the bass quest line so definitely
check that video out and let me know in
the comments if you have a favorite
secret or Easter egg from the game now
if you somehow watch our videos and
haven't played Hogwarts like you yet
there's a free way to try it out right
now at least if you're a PlayStation
Plus premium subscriber honestly I doubt
this will be relevant to many of you
here but hey maybe you know someone
who's been wanting to try out the game
before they buy it well this would give
them a great way to do just that that
being said the trial is only for 45
minutes so that would probably be just
enough time to finish the first main
mission of the game but I don't think
they'd have time to reach Hogwarts in
that amount of time so with all of that
being said what is next for Hogwarts
Legacy there was no news at the
PlayStation showcase no news at the
summer game Fest it seems like all the
attention and focus has moved to that
Nintendo switch version of the game
which is slated to release on November
14th so I think the big question now is
can they move on to anything before that
switch version is out and when I say can
they move on to anything I mean like a
DLC like a sequel I've said for a while
and continue to say that I do believe
Hogwarts Legacy will get DLC at some
point to me it is entirely a question of
when and not if however I do think the
switch version being pushed back so far
apart from the other versions does raise
some interesting questions so this video
right now I'm recording in June of 2023
so that leaves six months until the
release of the Nintendo switch version
that is a lot of time so we have this
six month stretch here where it is very
possible we could get very little news
at all on Hogwarts Legacy all that being
said the switch version has always been
in kind of this bizarre position because
it was not originally announced I don't
know if it wasn't originally part of the
plan or what the exact situation was
there but somewhere along the lines
somebody at WB said okay we need to get
this out on switch and then there's also
the elephant in the room and that's the
fact that the Nintendo switch is not
long for this world yes it is one of the
best selling consoles of all time I
think it will be worthwhile for Hogwarts
Legacy to be on there however Nintendo
could literally drop an announcement any
day of an inte Nintendo switch successor
what is coming after the Nintendo switch
switch 2 switch Pro and I suppose there
are definitely pros and cons when it
comes to how you go about announcing a
DLC and of course all of this is
predicated on how much they actually
have done and if they are working on a
DLC when it's ready that's the big thing
of course but Hogwarts Legacy just had
so much hype when it launched it had
such a huge impact released to critical
Success commercial success sold a ton of
copies so I think the big question is
can they drum up the support can they
drum up the excitement again when it
comes to announcing a DLC now I don't
think they'll ever be able to top what
they did at launch that was just an
absolutely incredible wave of momentum
maybe we see something like that for the
sequel way down the road here's my
prediction September 1st 2023 back to
Hogwarts Day last year was absolutely
huge for Hogwarts Legacy on back to
Hogwarts day I mean it was a main
feature so I don't see them letting that
go by without announcing something maybe
it's not a DLC but I for sure expect
them to have a presence announcing
something there so that gives us just
under three months until then what do
you guys think do you expect that we'll
see something at back to Hogwarts day or
before then in the meantime maybe I'll
just play the old Harry Potter games
after all I just went on a quest to buy
every single one of them and that let me
tell you it was an incredible experience
if you haven't seen that video yet check
it out on the right side of your screen
next as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon